maybe you can't cause there
ain't no way you can't explain what you
don't understand what the hell
what the hell
[Music]
i knew i was singing it in front of
radio country radio that isn't used to
political statement types of songs
they're under fire
for not a lot of women being brought up
the charts are getting the same support
as the men
and so i knew that there was a lot of
weight with that
and with this song and i kept just
saying to myself
music is so much bigger than me it's so
much bigger than you
and this song right here specifically
is not about me it is every woman's song
whether they think they've gone through
it or not
[Music]
in the country music industry we're
about peace love and harmony we don't
want to ruffle anybody's feathers we
want everybody to feel
comfortable but a lot of times it it
you want everybody to feel comfortable
but so you're comfortable but i'm the
one that's uncomfortable
and i've been in a lot of rooms where
everybody else is comfortable and i'm
very uncomfortable wonder
so when i get those karen's and heavens
that come for me on twitter
i will put their
their hate on display for everybody to
see so that they know
that it's not okay like i'm not making
this
up like i get this on a daily basis
hateful messages oh well then why don't
you just leave
leave what leave this country that i was
born in what it does to the country
community i think it
it scares people in the country music
community it
scares them into silence and i was
silent
for a very long time and
it was detrimental to my heart god gave
each and every one of us
a voice a heart a mind
and our own personal experiences and
when you shut that
up and shut that out you're shutting up
what god created us to be
[Music]
hallelujah
you